[Music]
kylie jenner is showing off her fit bod
nearly a week after revealing she gained
60 pounds during her second pregnancy
baby number two number two
congratulations thank you
over the weekend the beauty mogul shared
this pic rocking a bikini while enjoying
a pina colada on vacation
kylie also posted this snap soaking up
the sun on a paddle board simply writing
in the caption happy girl these vacay
picks come after kylie revealed how much
weight she gained during her second
pregnancy she and her longtime beau
travis scott welcomed a baby boy back in
february
alongside a photo of herself on a
treadmill kylie wrote quote gained 60
pounds again this pregnancy down 40
pounds just trying to be healthy and
patient walking and pilates is my
favorite combo
but this isn't the first time she's been
open with fans about her postpartum
journey
in march kylie confessed that getting
back into shape has been difficult
i just want to say
to my postpartum moms that postpartum
has not been easy
it's not been easy it's very hard
it's this experience for me personally
has been a little harder than with my
daughter
it's not easy mentally
physically
spiritually
it's just
crazy and yeah i didn't want to just get
back to life without saying that
but kylie is keeping things positive and
offered an encouraging message for all
the mamas out there it's okay
not to be okay once i
realized that i was putting some
pressure on myself and i just keep
reminding myself i made a whole human
beautiful healthy boy
and we have to stop putting pressure on
ourselves to
be back not even physically just
mentally
after
after birth so yeah
just sending some love
while kylie has been sharing her life
after baby number two's arrival she has
yet to share any pics of her son
his name well it was initially revealed
as wolf but the couple later announced
they changed their minds wolf was never
on our list
um
it just was actually something
chloe suggested and i like don't do this
i like the name i don't think anything i
still like that's full i
i just wasn't him but kylie says she and
travis are steps closer to deciding the
new moniker
we have some really strong options but
we haven't officially changed we have
some placeholders so before i officially
change it i just want to be sure you're
seeing that little personality
[Music]